[cheers and applause]
[light piano music]
[telephone ringing]
- Answer that damn telephone.
- Who's calling?
- We won't know unless you
answer the telephone.
That is how the telephone works.
- Uh, Ms. Jackson, a moment.
I was speaking to a colleague at
Bell Laboratories.
He said they are looking for
bright young minds,
outside-the-box thinkers.
- Really? I've been mapping out
this idea
for a phone line module that
indicates a caller's name
when the telephone rings.
- Okay, Ray Bradbury,
save that for your science
fiction novels.
They're looking for
practical applications.
- Sometimes, to realize a
dream,
the only voice worth
listening to is your own.
- ITT is working on a go
anywhere phone,
but we--we've
got nothing.
- What if we had a display that
informs you who's calling?
- What is your name?
- Dr. Shirley Ann Jackson.
- Well, Ms. Dr. Shirley Ann
Jackson,
I'd say you've been dipping into
your own medicine bag.
[laughter]
[light piano music]
[telephone rings]
- Who could possibly be
calling at this hour?
- Wouldn't it be great to know?
- It would.
- [scoffs]
Well, tell that to my bosses
down at the lab.
They won't listen to me.
- I'm telling you, you believe
in yourself,
they ain't got no choice but to
believe in you.
[laughter]
- Calling line identification
presentation
with an analog
system interface.
- Calling line identification.
Now I've seen it all.
- So if your mother-in-law
calls, you don't have to answer.
[applause]
- From executive producers
Pharrell Williams
and Oprah Winfrey comes the
true story of one woman's
struggle to change our world.
Starring Jazmyn Simon as
Shirley Ann Jackson
With Ray Wise and Frank Clem
in the studio-mandated roles of
white savior...
- This is going to make those
telemarketers think twice
about interrupting America's
family dinner.
- And make us very, very
rich men.
[laughter]
[telephone ringing]
[cheers and applause]
- You know, if E equals M-C
squared,
then I should be able
to cook this at 400 degrees
for 27 minutes and it not
be dried.
I don't really know
what's going on.
- It--it...
- I don't know, Morris.
I just--
- We need to pray on it.
Dear, Lord, please un-dry the
chicken just, uh,
add some moisture deep, deep
into the thigh meat.
- Yes, Jesus.
- Season the--the vegetables
with your blessings
and some extra salt.